You know, sometimes you get a little frazzled when you're on a new account and you realize
you don't have, you don't have your proper settings and your music and your stuff so
we ball is my music too loud I sent no these are not nude models
every every body except for my except for except for Azra is my body
so you're only technically looking at me I sent I sent the the the base okay so I didn't put any
details in the base but I sent it to management and I was like manager is this safe for YouTube
and you know what manager said no I rushed and just like like MS painted like the black
sensor bar bra and boy shorts okay she be body is mine she be body is mine I can draw in boobs
probably every every okay shut up about boobas they're all my they're all my body except for Azra
they're all my body except for Azra and Azra even then I was like it's kind of kind of
it's a base it's a base shut up I think back in underwear one I think I was late too late for this
where is it wait okay oh yeah yeah that's better give me a second actually give me a second give me a
second manager uh base too I literally had like no time to like do this hold on I'll do I'll do I'll open
where is it it isn't downloads based on yeah that's better that's better why is everyone
nerfed except for Azra because everyone's body is my body okay everyone's body is my body even
the canoes even the canoes are my body
yeah this is better thank you manager manager
so all of these all of these are my body sorry I'm laughing too hard
I'm a little frazzled
I'm a little frazzled because all this time I'm
I like ran up and down the stairs because I was like oh my gosh I need to go do a
final meeting then I ran up then I ran down so I'm a little I'm a little like uh okay
so yeah uh I had lots of planned didn't pan out sorry I hit I hit you my I hit you my
the microphone not like my cunny or something I cannot undo Azra's body is Azra's body because
if I put my body on Azra's body that's just I can't get away with that
anyways uh welcome to the stream everyone uh I was not as ill I was ill prepared for the stream
simply because I thought that my settings in my other account would transfer over and it didn't
so there's a lot of funky wonky settings uh that uh it's not it's not good okay
it's not good so um I'm basically playing test out the thing so the the uh
the program I'm using right now is a free program free program senpai called Krita
so Krita is free to use so anyone who wants to draw or something you may draw along with me
Krita K R I T A so it's called Krita
so it is a program that is free to use so if anyone's looking for a free drawing program
it's pretty good it comes with all these brushes hold on I gotta move myself you can't see these
brushes it comes with all these brushes you can use in the corner here did you tweet that you
went live no no one more thing that I forgot to do I was so frazzled did I do that now
okay give me a second I'm so frazzled frazzled dazzled
today's tea is gingerbread
okay let me get some stuff oh my gosh I know I know glitz and glam today
I will be drawing date outfits for the girls the girls uh the base is made by
by one of my gal pals who was like yeah I'm into graphic design let me just you know make a base for
you and I said okay yeah they'll save me a little bit of time
I'll save me a little bit of time and I said okay and yeah I wasn't that much time saved because
I I was like oh shit I'm forgetful today
I'm forgetful today so give me a second as I
do my tweet I forgot to tweet I'm live I'm live not lie lie live PS post script I'm live
stream floor mercy tag yeah
double whammy and I'm with the double post where's my where's my link what thank you for the raid
strongy welcome to their thank you for the raid give them
up up up up up up thank you thank you thank you I saw I caught a bit of the stream
and yeah yeah it looked super chaotic and really fun so I hope everyone had a great time at
strongy's stream you can good reef links convince strongy to stop streaming
that's the first hold on let me get my shareable link ha ha he he live right now oopsies
link there remove it remove the HBTTS
is on the right account it's on the right account okay
whoo
yeah mommy has a has a stream addiction an addiction
took more effort than it should have should have had well uh let's just say uh fishing fishing is
strong is strong with this one oh no let me move myself up a little bit so you can see my cool
handy dandy paintbrush
does that kind of look sus
eh whatever
ah whatever okay so we are using Krita I am using a drawing tablet
that I bought uh from what brand are you hooli on from hooli on so it's just a screen uh
not a screen tablet it's just a kind of like a drawing tablet so today we are gonna do some
certain themes they're all going to be um sorry I'll be yelling because my my tablet is over here
my uh tablet is over here and you you are the microphone is over here I adjusted my desk I
didn't take into account that it would be like this uh my hooli on is called Kizuna
did I get it because it reminded me of Kizuna I maybe but it also it has cats on it
it has cats on it um maybe one day I'll buy a like a screen tablet
so um that's my tool I also have a tour box which I have not configured with this account
what is the word of the day the word of the day is uh
I I didn't think of a word of the day
frazzled yeah let's do frazzled because I was frazzled
ha ha ha
frazzled suffering
am I french today no I am an artist
ha
merci modiste artist extraordinaire
where are the little mustaches
thank you uh
me please it's my fetish could you do a cover of cycle gram cycle what
merci modiste artiste no french mustache oh my gosh you're so picky hold on I'll put on the mustache for you
I'll put on the mustache for you I just I I thought you wanted to see the all my beautiful face
but here you can have this cool mustache yeah
wait wait wait
now I can cope
the way it moves on me is so funny
isn't it supposed to be smaller though um
I'm lacy I'm too lazy lacy to trim it so today um I have decided on themes for everyone
did they influence me on it not really okay so theme today is
let's go for azura cheek
scrawny
is on a date I think uh what is it
oh what was the thing called I decided for her I totally forgot what it was
um
moving on I'll come back to me princess
yes
this stuck in my head for a while so pro cautious
emo
lady
chic it's chic not cuck chic
it says chic oh my god
where's my eraser tool that the eraser tool that's not the eraser tool
and you're not used to your settings everything becomes frazzled and you didn't have time to
use your settings so now you have to make everything more difficult more difficult than it already is
ah it doesn't erase properly because it acts like a real eraser okay you know what screw this um
motherly
and
scrawny is
honestly
I don't know why but
but I was like in my mind scrawny was like a raver but I might change that
I was thinking maybe my made princess or star studded superstar
I might actually just go for e-girl
all right
ha ha ha thank you me suck up best for the 3 3 3
yeah the c-girl yeah c-girl
so let's do another layer actually um in this uh they they are going to be very sketchy these
are not going to be like professional our style so we're gonna end up kind of like doing a more
sketchy style like you would do with block coloring and uh that you would see at
in what do you call it
you'll see in um
fashion design sketches okay okay so uh I want to start off with the pencil of course
because pencils are always nice to use I forget my settings mercy can you frown again
like that
okay so
where is my where's my okay we'll start the person who I thought about the most was
emi the entire time because emi
it's gonna be so pixelated it looks so much better when it's zoomed out uh pixelated is
is uh because she said that she wanted a kind of an emo outfit so in my idea I wanted kind
of like a precocious a precocious uh little sister emo so basically um the little sister
archetype wants to impress her big bro on the first date and so she wants to look a little
bit more mature a little bit more mature but still very youthful a little bit coquette coquette
uh reflecting off the feelings of uh of the style of what was of uh
gosh I need the movie name again I need the director for this movie
uh
Stanley Kubrick's Stanley Kubrick's uh film lolita
so the fashion back then as well so I've wanted to kind of go in that kind of gothic thing gothic uh
uh precocious uh adolescence that's my that's my um that's my feel that's my that's what I want
to feel like in this outfit so this outfit is going to to kind of reflect emi's darker self
but also her her uh attempt of being seen as a grown-up
wow I'm like explaining something and then people are like we don't care we don't care just draw
okay so with that I've decided we'll do a base
I do a base in my mind
in my mind was I was kind of inspired a little bit by seeing a kind of like
y2k dress that had like all these like neat needle buttons right uh these needle buttons
and a kind of little tiny little v tiny little v the dress was a little bit boxy
which I really enjoyed uh seeing so a boxy dress
by the way this is my body if you think this is emi's body this is my body that I just pasted on
emi her neck's missing uh because I didn't have time to fill it in so there you can get her her
neck like that so uh if if she's a little bit more curvaceous than usual that's because this is me
so I was inspired by a dress that I saw it I think it was like someone uh drew the girls
from blue archive in dirike so specifically um what's her face
the emo one and
the kind of emo one
the smart one in the that's that's with
the dumb the dumb girl
yeah that one
no no no the idiot the idiot from the idiot group the one that bombed everything
and the one girl that pretend she's cool kaioko yeah it was it's kaioko anyways she had a similar
dress like that so the dress had some like rivets and stuff in it which I thought was like really cool
so for emi I was thinking it would be like that um with with that with a nice cute little choker
why why because I think that's very emo I think it's very emo of her
yeah the idiot group yeah problem solver 68 yeah thank you thank you thank you
I was like kind of the emo girl she was wearing kind of a uh a black dress so I love
black dresses black dresses when you think of little black dress it's a dress that's supposed
to go with everything and looks very good on a lot of people so it had rivets and stuff so
we're gonna just fill in this black dress to give it um the feel that um that it is a dress
by the lake we're gonna give her a black dress but then we're gonna emo fire right we're gonna
emo fly black dress we're we're we're talking about um we're talking about my immortal black
lace gloves hot topic emo okay after this
and where where uh the main character describes her outfit for like a total of five pages before
the chapter begins it's great
we're gonna do like a more goth than emo that I now that I think about it
curse me oh my elbow
have you read my immortal dough it's like a pilgrimage towards
towards um
pilgrimage towards um
like internet culture I guess so
what I have designed in mind I designed this in my mind last night and like in the shower
so what we have here is an open zipper outfit which I think is kind of cool
so the zipper uh the attaches around here
and underneath the dress will be another layer another layer I was thinking red of a red fabric
that it's kind of pleated pleated um
um
pleated down so I think that's kind of cute
I hope Emmy kind of likes this design because I think it's like it's got that childish uh
goth look to it but like is also pretty email uh I went to a friend's house to shower
you went to a friend's house to shower my water is still off by the way uh senpai
so we got the pleatedness I don't know if I like this brush but that's okay
the pleated dress underneath it's it's a little bit um
um more
more goth and then like here are the rivets this is like a very rough drawing so rivets
all the way through on it's wonderful okay it gives her kind of like that oof zoom out please
thank you kind of that goth goth look as well if you look at email email back then was uh was kind of
mixed with um
mixed with like the scene with scene and stuff so because it was mixed in with scene and kind of
like email emails mixed in with scene with notably with a lot of
arm warmers uh bracelets etc uh we're gonna go for very cute little arm warmers
and so we're gonna go with the arm warmers here
okay arm warmers I was thinking striped arm warmers so we'll go like this
and so to match the other side we have
the red the red stripes in between
I know this is very rough but I hope uh chat excuse me senpais can visualize it
oh senpais can visualize the sort of uh
cute little little goth gothicness to it chat senpai
the hair color doesn't exactly fit with the goth email theme
shh shh I didn't have if I had time to stew their hair I would because I would put
emmy into a messy bun okay I would put emmy into messy buns messy buns that had like little spikes
sticking out okay that that's really cute
and ow ow ow you can have highlights and stuff later but
okay
going down back then there was very fashionable um garters hanging garters
which I thought would look really cool like they're kind of like bout garters
that would look really cool on on emmy
I think over here she should get like some some some
uh so it'll be like kind of little little eyelet holes goes through here
and of course it's gonna be black why because black matches everything
yeah the image the emmy edge if you will
and then over here we can have the like classic
classic like spiked spiked wrist wrist uh spiked wrist bands with the studs in them
well I can't draw
there you go um
um
we are not giving her vans we are giving her dock martins
okay
we are giving her dock martins
dock marks
so what I want emmy to have here is like really we've
have about a little below the knee socks oh shit
we're giving her dock martins dock martins
which are basically combat boots
I feel like demonicas would be a little too ornate for the outfit so I feel like
already on top it's a little bit like middle heavy so I feel like you know the top here
should be a little bit more sparse and down here would be a little bit more simpler so dock
martins are usually combat boots
combat boots and yeah and I feel like emmy would be like big brother hold on big brother
I'm gonna stomp on your nuts
so that's why I'm giving her combat boots because that's what I think she would do
I'm so bad at drawing shoes I've never been good at drawing shoes so we'll we'll we say fuck it
oh they're gonna be like fake dock martins
dock martins have like stripes on it and then
who
excuse me
So, yeah, we got the boots.
And the boots has the little lip on it.
I suck at drawing shoes, don't ever let me draw shoes ever again.
We're visualizing.
You guys can use your imaginations.
It's here.
I don't know.
It's a little lace.
Deckled out.
There we go.
I have to do at least draw nine more shoes.
I'm going to pretend that I'm not going to draw nine more shoes.
By the way, I'm going to pretend that's not a thing.
I hate shoes the most.
Like, do I like the look of shoes?
Of course, I look...
These suck.
It's okay.
We're just...
We're in a sketch phase, right?
Nobody's noticing.
It's tough for me.
There we go.
But, yeah, I'm thinking her cautious.
She looks so cute, right?
She looks so cute.
If I could, I would put on red eyeshadow for her.
I would move her buns here.
I would move them toward the top of her head.
I would add in the little spray, sparse hairs to make them look like they're spikes.
Like that.
That's what I would do.
Lipstick.
I think a lip gloss would be a pewter.
Last so-to-all?
Can I even do that?
That's what I would think.
I don't know.
I'm not used to Cretan too much, so bevier curve, dynamic, move on.
Close.
She looks just too old, polygons.
I'm very new to this, so I don't know.
I don't know.
I only know how to do this in Photoshop.
But, yeah.
Okay, forget that.
Forget that.
I'll just redraw it.
Is this easier?
No, but I would just redraw Amy's hair up here, like the side here.
And it would be cute little messy buttons on the side.
I think that would be cute, by the way.
So that was my original vision, and then the little tools here would be the little pin pals.
So it would be like little pin pals, but red.
I think Cretan's last so-to-all is the bean shape selection tool at the bottom.
This thing?
No, freehand?
Oh, maybe it is.
Can I move it?
Sorry, give me a second.
I'm still learning from here.
Can I move it?
Can I turn it?
It just imagined this.
I'd have a layer below it.
Never mind, you know what?
Can we just...
I'll just wipe this out here.
Is this...
Is Mercy kind of dumb?
Yes.
Can you just...
Where's my color tool?
Yeah, we'll just...
Can I fill that?
Forget it!
I give up.
What is this?
I wanted to pick a thing...
I'll learn Cretan later.
I'll learn Cretan later, okay?
Okay, shut up.
I'll learn Cretan later.
A lot of Emile and Goth, of course, have skulls and stripes and fishnets and stuff like that.
So, guess what?
We're going to add socks!
Striped socks, obviously.
It's all white, isn't it?
I had better tools when I was on the side.
So, we have socks right over here.
I'm thinking about adding in a bit of white, white socks, so that it can give that little bit of emile contrast.
I don't want Emile to be like, fully stripe-heavy.
So, I might just do a plain sock on the other, or no sock, it depends.
What am I feeling?
No, no, no, screw it.
Screw it.
You know, I said I wanted socks.
I changed my mind.
I'm going to go...
I'm going to change my mind.
It means going to steal my style.
We're going to do fishnets.
She's going to steal my style.
Why? Because I think it will balance it out a little more.
I think it will look really cute otherwise.
Ooh, I have an idea.
We can have her have like a little, her tattoo over here instead.
That would be cute, I think.
Or on the other side, I don't really know.
I wanted her hair to be like up here, but I just didn't have time.
So, that, and then if she wanted, she could have her little...
Her little second necklace.
Layering necklaces is very in trend nowadays.
So, it gives it a little bit of a modern twist.
She can have a little like skull necklace or something.
Or a crystal, whatever, you know?
Of course, it wouldn't be Emmy without a few little cute, cute things.
So, she can have herself, her little hammer here still.
She can keep her little hammer there.
Who knows, maybe she wants a little knife, depends on how she feels.
Maybe a little spells and stuff.
She can be held onto these beautiful little garters.
She's nice to have options. She can have whatever she wants.
It's Emmy after all.
So, Emmy's outfit is very simple, but I think with the zipper opening dress,
with the pleated adding double textures, as well as kind of like having a upper,
a little bit of a heavy upper and like the lower part is a little bare bones.
The plainness, it gives it a bit more cute look.
Simplistic look makes it more cute.
Not very heavy.
It's not very heavy.
It won't be as...
It's overall a very plain shape, but the plainness gives it the more adolescent look to it.
It gives kind of a little bit of mature vibe to it.
Very cute in my opinion.
So, there we have it.
There we have Emmy's gothic outfit.
I think I'm done unless...
Unless Senpai's have better ideas.
I feel like base is based off what I did.
I think this is pretty decent because the kind of like simpler look makes her look a bit more mature.
Mature, but her petite-ness makes her look very young, very young and youthful.
Of course, like a little sister.
This is up to Emmy if she wants to like base off of it or something,
but this was what I had in my head and that was the clearest image I had.
She was the first one I had in my head.
I was like, yes, my emo goth.
That's what I had in the head.
This is the Emmy outfit.
She may have anything she wants with it.
She can have a...
She can carry her little backpack of her pin pal.
Because the plush backpacks were in back then.
I don't remember what pin pals really looked like.
But she can have a pin pal backpack if she wanted.
As well.
Makes it accessorizing.
Looks very cute in my opinion.
She can hold it in her hand to show off or she can have it on her back.
So when she turns around you're like, you know,
when she turns around she's like, are you looking at my backpack?
Big brill.
Can't you have a gun though? The gun's in the backpack, okay?
Use your imagination, senpai.
I don't quite remember what they look like, but you know, maybe...
Oh dear, I actually put it on a rice.
She can't even have like a big zipper here.
It just has all her little goodies and stuff in it.
Wonderful. I think this is a great start.
Let me just do some color stuff. Where is orange?
Let me just fill in some stuff.
Because we have a lot of girls to go through.
We have a lot of girls to go through.
But I think this is pretty fucking cute if you ask me.
I don't remember what pin pals look like, but I think this is how my pin pal will look like.
There you go.
I will do the two canoes first.
I'm sorry for my...
Lack of Photoshop skills, because I just don't have time to draw a full head and full base.
But this is Emmy's outfit if I could remove these.
I can remove these and move them up here.
And have them a little bit more sparse so that her little hair strays will look like spikier.
Use Tomatoes 5 up and down.
There are tomatoes now.
Cookie scale with pins.
There are unripe tomatoes now.
They're fine.
Oh well, I think that's cute. I still think it's cute.
I don't remember. Oh well, they're orange tomatoes.
Don't point out tomatoes, it looks like you're throwing them at me.
Cookie.
That's Emmy's outfit.
Okay, so for my beautiful icy.
My beautiful icy. Oh my gosh, sorry. I still love how I designed her outfit. I'm sorry. I'm admiring my own work.
For icy, I want her to be a princess. Why? Because she deserves to be a princess.
But not just any princess. We're going Elsa with her. She's going to be an ice princess.
And you know what? She lives up somewhere real cold. I don't know where.
So she needs to be warm. Okay. She needs to be warm.
But as well with icy, she's a little bit feral, so we don't want something too prim and proper.
Understood? Understood, Senpai? We don't want something too prim and proper. We want it to be easy moving.
Easy moving, but also very cute. Not completely prim and proper. Just a little bit.
Maybe give it kind of like, you know, the fallen princess type of look.
Okay, we keep her pause. Yeah, just ignore the fact that she has no pause.
The reason why is because this is my body. I just took away the tits.
Okay, I just took away, you know.
I just took away the tits. These are all my body except for Azra. Azra is not my body.
This is all my body, okay, so that everyone has to look at me.
Okay. So for icy, I also take into effect that she's also a DJ or a club.
So we might go with a little rave princess for her. It depends on how I feel.
But starting from my head thought, I want her to have these big fuzzy leg warmers.
I don't know if it will look good, but we'll see.
Well, gray, we will use gray for them.
The leg warmers, you often see them at raves because...
Actually, I don't know why.
I don't know why.
I honestly don't know why.
I don't go to raves, so I don't know their culture.
Because it's outside and it gets cold, okay.
So I really want I see to have these big fuzzy, beautiful, beautiful leg warmers.
We'll color these in so it gives the effect that looks like it's fur.
I also wanted to listen, I wanted Senpai to listen to music today, but I don't want to get hit by copyright.
I want Senpai to listen to my music instead.
There's a lot of differences.
It's really hard, at least on YouTube, to have music.
If you export it, the music is gone because you can separate the audio for that.
That's not really possible on here, so I couldn't do something like that.
We'll make the top a little gray just because I think it will go nicely with this beautiful white fur.
Okay, let's continue on.
I know rave outfits tend to have a little bit of a...
The silhouette is very narrow within, but on the arms and the back, it tends to be more fluffy and pretty.
So we're going to go with a cute little design.
I think she would look like a great little princess if I can just make the silhouette cute, like a little snow princess.
Ignore the fact that this is my body. I am asking you, once again, to ignore the fact that this is my body.
Long style, maybe?
Crown, I think she would love a crown.
But also, I think around here would be wonderful with a fur over the show, draping, draping, draping sleeves.
I think that's cute as well.
I love it when the shoulders, usually I don't think.
Correct me if I'm wrong, but I don't think it's very common to completely cover the shoulders in some way in rave outfits.
Is it weird for Icy to wear fur? She is wearing fur in her regular outfit!
Of course, I want her to have a beautiful crown as well.
A beautiful crown as well.
Because she is our princess, I think a little wired crown would be very nice on her.
But as well, for the sleeves, I feel like it would be really cute if she had the very long kimono sleeves.
I want to make it over the top for her outfit, but I feel like it just gives her that sense of warmth.
Meanwhile, most of her will be kind of exposed.
It makes her look more queenly and princessy, and it makes her look cute.
So here, it would be kind of like, here would be the outfit, and then we can add in, so, no, that's not bad.
Here, let me draw this so it kind of seems like it's an easier outfit to look at.
No, you know what? Screw that. I don't want round, no, I don't want sharp.
She's cute, so she'll get a little bit of a round breastplate.
And then down here, I would say that she'll get, like, a classic rave-er, rave-er stripes, I guess?
Oh, no, no, no, I've never been to a rave before, and I don't party, okay? I don't party senpai, so if anyone doesn't like this idea...
My bad!
I think it's cute. A lot of rave outfits are very ornate as well, so I'm thinking, like, a little bit of, like, a heart here would be very cute.
Yeah, let's expose her tummy. You know what? Expose her tummy. That makes her look very cute.
What? Heart cutouts here to match the top? These are cutouts, so I just think they're... yeah.
Is that too much? Hmm. Hmm. Eh, I'm lost in the sauce. Lost in the sauce as in, like, I'm just, like, debating on, like, how princess it can be without making it too overbearing.
I'm debating. I'm debating, because, like, I'm not very familiar with rave outfits, and I don't want to make it be, like, oh, this is too rave, or it's not cute and not princess rave enough.
Where's her light up pinkie? I'll draw it. I'll draw it later. Around her neck. She can have her royal ring. She can have her ring.
I've never been to a rave, so I thought of this outfit for her, and then I was, like, I don't actually know if people will wear this to raves. That's the problem.
I think it's actually too much behind her right now. What did I do? Oh. Oh, wrong base. No. That's the side. Okay. I might actually erase that, because that's too much.
Like, I think Emmy's design was, like, more flourished in my mind, and Icy's was not quite there yet. It was not quite there yet. Like, basically the legs and the sleeves were there, but then the middle of the outfit wasn't there yet.
Like, basically the sleeves were, like, yes, I've got it. Like, it's going to be that sparkly fabric that, like, they have at raves that people love so much. It shimmers and shines, and, you know, it'll be kind of the same thing here.
I think this is better. I think, yeah, I think that's better, actually. Sequences, no. It's, like, kind of, like, very sparkly, the very sparkly material. It's not actually sparkly, but just sparkle.
It gives her a little bit of a cuter, mature look. I do want her to have, like, a little raver backpack and stuff as well. So, actually, we're going to do a little bit of some changes here, because I didn't like what I did down here.
So, we're going to erase that. We're going to erase that. I'm so messy. I'm so sorry I wasn't as prepared for the stream as I was before. I was going to do the heart cutouts, but now I think it's too much.
A new heart cutout. But now I think it's too much.
Ugh, you're such a cute princess. You're such a cute princess. I love her.
Okay, let's try. Let's try. We got to give her the cutesy princess look, so.
Brace her off. Right on. This time we'll do this, and then we'll do, like, a little ruffle skirt.
Okay, yeah, there we go. Now I'm cooking. Now I'm cooking. Now I'm cooking. Lip cooking.
I love what you did with Emmys. Emmys was already in my mind for a while, and you know what, Azraza's also was on my mind, and I have a few, like, ideas for, for, for...
Shibi, and then Strawny. I have a few ideas for as well, but it's not fully cooked up, like, I see.
Like, I see. So there we go. There we go. Yes, cute. Cute. Cute. Very cute. That looks so much better. Oh my gosh, why didn't I do this before?
Classic grave princess look.
Here. Cute. The color as well, and then here. It's like this, so it's cinched in the middle.
Cinched in the middle, cinched in the middle, with a little bit of extra fabric hanging out. We'll take this color, and then we add in a few little ribbons, because that's what she would want.
Because that's what she would want. And then I'm thinking her neck looks a little bare.
So we're gonna add in a little bit of a little, of a simple necklace with her binky there. She can wear her, like, bedazzled little binky and stuff. I think if I can get this to not...
I can get this to somehow look rough, you know, over and underneath. I think we're just about done. I see as well.
It's really hard to work with, because sometimes on skin it just doesn't show up.
Especially when you want to, like, highlight some things, but then it just looks like it's just white, you know?
So yeah, I think I see how if it's really cute, she can wear a little backpack that makes her look like, you know, like she can wear her little light up backpacks or whatever that makes her look like, I don't know, a little fairy.
Give me a second. I need to see what a butterfly wings look like.
Okay.
Okay, there we go. What do you think? I think it's cute. I think she'd like it. I think she'll move around with it. It's not completely prim. I think it's still good.
It still gives her a little bit of the feral look to it. Yeah, yeah, I think that's good. I'm not that much... I'm not a very... I'm not a seasoned artist or anything so.
That's what I think and I'm just like, you know, Rave's, yeah, she'll love it. She can have this outfit for when she goes to Rave's and, you know, it's easy to move in, she'll be able to dance and she'll be able to do her hunting as well.
Please ignore the hands. I'm too lazy to draw and pause. She will have her cute little polar bear paws. Bear feet, by the way. Oh gosh.
Oh shit. Give me a second. They're chunky white boots. They're chunky white boots, yeah. Shut up. Shut up, shut up, shut up. They're chunky white boots, yeah.
White's always like an off-grey. Yeah. Shit. Imagine those are like the... Hold on. I can do so much better than this. Little grippers. I don't know.
Fuck it. She gets the platform boots that have like fake snow on them. You're good. There you go. Actually, that does look good. It's platform. Transparent platforms. Okay.
I think it looks great. Add it to her eye. She'll love it, okay? She can stomp on it like glass. Yeah, it's like Cinderella, okay? Cinderella, Cinderella. Oh my gosh, I'm gonna get something. It's fine.
That's fine. I feel like shebeads. Not shebeads. Gosh, Emmy. Emmy and I see would like go out together in these outfits. I think these are cute. You really want these girls to stomp on stuff. She really would stomp on you, okay? She'll bite you.
She'll bite you and stuff. So I think these two will definitely go out and have some fun. Maybe go to the ice hole or something. Maybe go on a girly get together like a cafe or something.
Things like that. I think that's cute, okay?
They're like besties, okay? They look so cute together. Yeah, I think it's cute. I think it's cute.
Okay, who do I start with next?
Next.
I'll do Azra because I already have a very simple outfit in mind. I have a simple outfit
in mind for her. Don't think that simple is bad. Simple shows off the goods, okay?
I'm winking, but you can't tell. I can't believe this is Kohai's body. This is the only one that's not my body.
What I want for Azra and I've been salivating at this, okay? I've been salivating at this idea.
Sleeveless turtleneck.
Sorry, I am cooming at the top.
I don't have steady hands for this right now.
I got my tour box working, but then it didn't decide not to work again.
You're doing what now?
Cumin. Cumin, yeah, cumin at the thought. You know, the spice.
I'm just going to fill this in because it's a lot.
I swear I'm going to be cooking.
I swear I'm going to be cooking with this thought.
It represents, I always love this type of like the sweater because it's so motherly.
Sorry, excuse me for being like this.
My entire life I was just like, that's too small.
I always misclick.
Too big. This is why I want my tour box to work, but it decided to not work like a little bish.
Sorry, excuse me.
She just looks so good in it. I thought it would look good, but now I'm right.
I was like, she'll look so good in like an oversized, like in this like kind of tight fitting sleeveless sweater.
I was like, she'll look so good in like an oversized, like in this like kind of tight fitting sleeveless sweater and I was like Turtleneck sweater, I was right.
I was right. She looks so good in it.
Sorry.
She looks so good in it.
Some lines, alright some lines.
There we go.
I'm gonna do a little over half. Of course I am. Of course.
Oh, god damn, she looks really good. She looks really good on that.
Okay, now.
I'm gonna add in.
Like, these are very popular nowadays.
Oh, I'm gonna get added.
A see-through button-up shirt that's kind of slipping off her shoulders.
Very popular nowadays.
So it's gonna be buttoned up over here, now it's falling off her and it's slightly, I don't care, as well.
I'll put in the details later, but I kind of want to give this effect transparency.
It's very popular nowadays, you can see it.
You'll see it a lot in like medias where it's kind of like this like very pretty transparency.
Hold on, let me grab a better, darker pencil for this.
Brush for this, so.
Maybe that's two?
Bigger?
So it's got this like transparency in it.
It's very hard to like show based off of the brushes, but I'm sure some artists has a better idea of how to like show this transparency.
Of like this kind of like chiffon dress shirt where they have like the button-ups and it's just falling off of her.
Because it can't fully fit.
It's all done, it's a grocery bag.
Now it's a see-through shirt, see-through chiffon shirt.
Okay, button-up shirt.
Shut up.
Pfft.
Solid layer change transparency.
Actually, that was a better idea.
Rosie too, that was a better idea, what the heck?
What was I thinking?
What was I thinking? Clearly not.
Pfft.
This paintbrush is terrible.
I thought I would be able to do like a thicker line with it, and then I didn't want to do it.
Where's my cursor?
There it is.
Okay, okay.
This one's better.
Okay.
Like that.
Actually, I could just leave it like that.
I think it gives it, I think I can just leave it like that, because then it'll make it look like it's, you know.
It makes it kind of look transparent, but also like with the outline, you can kind of see what I'm going for.
Sort of.
Pfft.
Underneath, you can see this really cool belt, and then I just want Azra to wear mom jeans.
Okay, I want her to wear mom jeans with this outfit.
It's so plain.
I know it's a plain outfit.
I know that she deserves better, but I am weak.
I am weak.
I am weak for the denim.
I am so weak for the denim with a big gold belt.
What's the difference between normal jeans and mom jeans?
A little bit more closely.
One is more shapely than the other.
You're welcome.
It tends to be more shapely and more, uh, holding on to the curves.
Am I mistaking them?
Whatever, she's wearing jeans.
Am I mistaking mom jeans?
Oh, whatever.
Whatever.
Whatever, I just...
Did you guys tell I gotta give up here?
It's bigger.
Is are my Senpai's gas lighting me because then that could be a thing
oh making this all in one layer call hi yeah I'm actually trying to like just
get the idea yeah yeah out first this is too big that's fine I'm getting the
idea out first and then maybe it's very rough it's very rough I don't want to
make this an entirely big stream where I spend the entire time meticulously
making beautiful outfits because I'm just like I just want the idea out I'm
designing I'm designing and I'm on a new program with all my all my tools that
I'm unfamiliar with off so now I'm just I don't I don't remember my settings from
my other accounts so I try to get into my other account and then it wouldn't work
and then yeah I'm just gonna get the idea out I'm just gonna get the idea out
because we're getting the idea out we're just winging it want her underneath this
layer very nice brown brown belt the transparency part got me got me
tilted I was like oh I can't show this as well as I wanted to reason why I wanted
like the kind of like chiffon sweater wearing on top is because I wanted to
like you like gives it that sexy feel the sexy mommy feel you know and then
with that we can have sexy mommy feel the denims should probably be a
different color but whatever and then we can have her have a very beautiful
and jumps a necklace based off of her
of course it's a classic she'll be wearing heels regular heels I can't draw
shoes
regular see let those as I think they look pretty I'm forgetful of how it looks
like very simple but I just really love it I just really love the way the way
that this looks it's simple it's plain you can tell she's mother yeah
oh she looks so good and like a sweater like a sleeveless sweater top oh that
just looks good I think that just good in my opinion I just it's simple but it's
an outfit that anyone can wear and I feel like she just wants to to go in
comfort her first date with you would be like heist it's like I don't know hi
sweetie kind of thing hi sweetie it's very it's very simple but I think yeah
she'll love it if she doesn't like the top of the like top she can just take it
off easy
okay mommy mommy time and then we'll do shabby
you
Okay.
How e-girl am I doing?
Cause I didn't have like a full, like a full, fully fra-
uh
Full idea for her at first, but then I was like
Now let's go, let's go with it
Actually, I think I got an idea
I got an idea, I got an idea
Mame will probably hate me for it
Or she'll love me for it, who fucking knows
Thank you
This is just me shooting out ideas already
I'm sorry if everyone's like, oh she's not a good artist at all
I fucking hate her
I don't care
Okay, whoosh
Let's sketch out the idea real fast
Let's sketch out the idea really fast here
Okay, I think that's a good basis
Reeflings
Reefling
Okay, okay
Let's go through bottom to top
Reefling
Slippers
House slippers
She's a gamer
Reefling house slippers
Thy high socks
Pleaded, uh
Pleaded plaid
Gert
With a slipping kind of lazy graphic font
Shirt will add in like belts
And stuff, make it very e-girl
With a kind of like fishy gamer headset
Bra, bra strap, what bra does she wear?
What bra does she, does mommy wear?
Reefling house slippers
So this is my thought
I've sketched it out just a little bit
Yes, yes
We are gonna cook
She going commando?
Well, if you know mommy enough
Come on, let me search up what reeflings look like
What reeflings look like again
Cause I'm kinda dumbble
Okay, I got it
House slippers
Alright
Yes, yes
Yes
Haha
Not gonna be perfect, sorry reeflings
It's not gonna be perfect
But I'm gonna do my best
To give you a basic idea of what I want
Because she's always steppin' on ya
Oh my gosh, she rented it
I love you
Ignore the fact that you can see her feet
Ignore it, ignore it, we're doing just the basic thing
If I had more time
I would probably make this better
But I don't
So, you're gonna just take it
Reeflings have a little bit of pink on their tentacles as well
Here we go
And, yeah
I love you
Okay, oh, okay
I'm so glad inspiration hit me like a fucking
Like a fucking truck, okay
Okay, ignore that this is gonna look like trash
For like a second
I want her to have
Like this is gonna be like as fast as I can possibly do it
Here's my pencil
Ansel, get over here, thank you
I took her like, shut up
Yeah
One side
The other side
I'll be more careful on this side
Whoo
It's like
Mercy, are your sketches as chaotic as this?
Yes, yes they are
If I had more time
Because my water got shut off
And I was like panicking a little bit
And then I was like, oh my gosh, I have so much to do
If I had more time
I would
I would probably have sketched this
Beforehand and started to add more design elements
And so
I think this is gonna be cute
So, what I wanted was like
Her little swan mix match socks
Cute
To be like her little
Swirlies like her hypnotism
Cuttle hypnotism thing
Of course
For the pink, she'll be having
Sure
Skirt
I was thinking more of her like
Pink swirly eyes
That she has is very simple
Skirt
Like this
Not gonna look that great
I'm so unfamiliar with everything
All my settings are gone
On this account and I was dumb
Ugh
Quintessential e-girl outfits
Or a plaid skirt
Sorry, that's just the way it is
Probably comes from like
You know
Schoolgirl stuff
But Quintessential, very plain
You know what? I'm thinking
I'm gonna see if this works but
You think we can get
Pink swirls on this side too?
Or is that too much?
I think that's too much
Maybe it's too much
Yeah, you know what? I'm scrapping that idea
I'm scrapping that idea
And then
I want her to still have
The kind of like
Cuttlefish
Her like little reefling colors
So we're gonna
Block this in
I
Have mummy look like a foal
Oh my gosh, what was that that run?
A foal
E-girl
E-girl gamer
Maybe give her a star on this cheek?
Sure
Lose the mustache, it's not fooling me
Look, the mustache moves funny, okay?
I think it's great
Oh
Gosh
I wish I had my own settings
Because these are a little rough
Discord kitten
Why don't you use your other account?
I'm not allowed to
Also safety reason
Safeties
Safety reasons
If I'm on this account
It's everything about it is mercy
And all my other account is personal
Is she the kitten or you're the kitten?
Shirt says discord moderator
I
Don't know I don't actually know what I should do for a shirt. So here's like I don't know
Think I need a different brush for that
Maybe this one
I'm experimenting with brushes
Sure, let's go with that
I would draw this cotton flag, but yeah
And then here
We can have her have
It can be whatever shirt, honestly
It can be like I
Survive scrawny's
Survive scrawny killing me. I don't know
Oh gosh, I need a better yellow than that
Tootery yellow not like gold, but like yellow
There's your star
Actually that looks really good
Cat ear headphones are not these headphones are fish fins. I just sketched it out really badly
I
Think it has elements of e-girl, but also elements of scrawny in it too
I am so bad at this
Let me just like Google what the like e-girl cat girl
Headphones kind of look like and then I'll just sort of mimic the look of it
This is so very sketchy though
Oh
Oh, I want to get to to she bees as well
So I don't want to like spend too long on each person even though I think I spent the longest on icys
I think I spent the longest on icys just because
I
Probably
Honestly, I've been watching you you haku show so everyone who watches who knows jury
The the announcement girl. Yeah, I kind of I'm kind of basing the fins off of her
And
Then maybe if I want I can add her like little little fins here
Make her look like a cullfish
Yeah
Give me a second. I want to make this even more e-girl than this is to go further beyond
This is to go further beyond
E-girl strappy strappy belt stuff
I
There we go
What was what's this menu
I click something
I click something. What the heck?
What the heck is that how do I undo that?
What menu has appeared and how do I undo it?
What did I do?
What the heck you wiki
Wow
Was it like a tool thing
My thingy gonna work now where I can rotate this
No
Press 5 to return to normal. Oh
Thank you senpai
Okay, oh my gosh
Thank you
The menu comes up by right clicking I believe I haven't touched it in a long time. So yeah, we are back. We are so back
Let me double-check strone's design because I love strone
Okay, hold on
It still has like her like plaster bandages on her on her arm there and
She still has it
Nice
Oh
Small details
Sorry, they're very sketchy they're very not great, but I think mommy looks pretty good and I think I
Think if I can get her like
Kind of greenish
These will look pretty decent as well. There you go
Well, I'm not the greatest artist or at least I'm not taking my time with this because I
I am like going boom
From from
Accelerate go make sure these designs are in
So yeah, I think that's a very cute very
Gamer girl. Yeah, we got
And now for for the lady the lady
We got two more left who's the two I got one more left
You know, I'm only doing my gen mates. I'm only doing my gen mates. I
Feel bad
No mercy outfit no mercy outfits, Holly
If you don't have a date idea for yourself, I figured six might be too much five might be doable
So I was like screw it my gen mates come first
Get it
My gen mates come first
Oh, I want a nice date outfit with our coal high
My
Outfit I really wanted like a sweater dress with like some ribbons on the side
But I was also like
Nope. Nope my girls first my gen mates are the most important
I'm sorry, I don't have super chats yet
We I think monetization is happening very soon, but not quite now
Sweater dress with ribbons, I think it was very romantic
Honestly in my mind. I was like, oh, you know, we're gonna date. I'll curl my hair for Senpai
I thought it was cute the idea to me was cute
Soon but not there yet
So yeah she be
I have a question for my senpai's
Big floppy hat or sunglasses because I want her to either have
Like she's going to be a lady boss lady, but a lady the big
Big floppy hat
Yeah, the big hat both both. Okay, I can do I can do both too, maybe
But we'll just do the design sketch first
Just a whoops
Little flourish here
Mm-hmm
We can do like the sunglasses here as well. She doesn't want to even look at you or she doesn't want you to look her in the eye
That's how
That's how she is I think her I think the pointed kind of like
Yeah
Kind of like the pointed sunnies would do fine
She is a lady
She is a lady and you will treat her as such
She will allow you to look into her eyes only when when you deserve it trash
It's a little off-sided
No, we're not doing
Can't do it. No big floppy hats have always been a sign of a lady. Okay of a lady
I still want she'd be to be business
So I had an idea where it was like
Look at this like beautiful pencil type skirt. It's like it's like
Stripes on it. It would be like so hot
It would be so hot to have like her pencil skirt in a color that she's not normally
In
And
Just for business cuz she would very much be all for business
The trench coat dress
This is called a peplum
So be a peplum is kind of like it sticks out like this and
Making it looks like a very mermaid look
To it she's still very business
But this time
It's more
And I want her to have like a little bit of like shoulder
Shoulder
Yeah
Under short or just like a bra or current honestly
I'm just giving it a thought and I'm kind of like
Would it be bad if like it's just the the the like deep
Uh deep drop trench coat with nothing underneath
What's underneath who knows she won't tell you and you won't get to see it, but you can use your imagination
And
Then of course the madam will have
Very nice little pantyholes
And the pantyholes
Only goes there why because it's one of those gartered pantyholes
Oh
Sorry, excuse me
I
Need to think of shoes give me a second as I like Google some shoes
For
Pantyholes stockings leggings are a different type of garments. Yep, sure are
Okay, I kind of like this
Okay
Let's start with black because I think that's what she would wear
I
Said sort of it wasn't you know what that was a lie that was a lie
Ignore my my very rushed bad art sort of it's fine. There you go
He's a me Azra. Hello Azra. I am designing everyone's outfits. I'm sorry
I made yours
Bate solely based off of the fact that I want you to wear like a turtleneck sleeveless sweater
And jeans and like the top here and might not be good might be hard to see but it's like a chiffon
Button-up shirt. So you it gives you that like extra sexy look
Well, I'll come to the stream
But yeah, I'm designing everyone's outfits
But yeah, I was like, uh-huh Azra needs us a turtleneck a sleeveless turtleneck
I can't do it. I'm coming at the thought
Strongie is like e-girl cuz she's playing lots of games
For I see I was like, yes, she has to be like, you know a raving princess and then
In me was like the goth
The goth little sister goth emo little sister
She can get whatever but she's also like, you know, she's ready. She's ready to stomp on someone
And then now we're work on Chibi who I'm just going to be like she's a lady business lady means business
Yeah, oh by the way, if anyone asks why does she be
Have like not her regular boobs because everyone's body
Is my body including the canoes
The only one who's has their body as a normal body is
Otherwise everyone else is me
I
So these are the designs I have so far I feel like Azra if I had time or if I had the ability right now I
Would
Put you in a ponytail. I would put you in a very long pony tail. I think that would be like hot
I
Think that would be hot
Like why is I see it looks smaller well, I put her in a platform
Choose and well she only looks shorter because it's pulled down a little bit
You like I love I love not the dead mom ponytail
Shut up. No, it's like the high ponytail where it would be like super cute. It'll be like a scrunchie
She's like mom, you know, she's ready to go
Go by groceries right after her after your date
There's the mercy drawing
I
Decided not to do the mercy drawing because I thought I would probably be wearing myself thin by that point. I
Think I would be wearing myself thin
Yeah, I would be I would be wearing myself thin if I did six so I'm just like five it is
My girls get to come first
So they they they get to
You could have done one pick space just for you to cook
I'm already tired to be honest doing four outfits already. I'm already tired
I'm already tired and whole whole wee-wee you have me
I'm the star of this child
So yeah five is a lot and as much as I love my girls as much as I love to design an outfit for me
I just don't have the time or the energy
And I don't want to like, you know, I don't want to what do you call it? I don't want to
Overshadow or make mine like particularly more interesting or anything
I've just had like these designs in my mind for a while
I've always had these designs in them in my mind for a while. Honestly my personal favorite
Is all of them I
Think my maze is pretty good, too
I know it's super simple and I know as her as is pretty simple, too
But I think they're they're pretty good. Honestly if I yeah, I would say they're pretty good
I think they're pretty good honestly, I think
They're all pretty good. I think
you know like
I see like a raver princess, and I think it's very good and then
It means being like kind of like a
Simpler outfit makes her look more mature, but like her pertinence makes her look
Still like a little sister. So I was like, yeah, this is great. I
Think
They all suit suit and I think
If they were to wear this out in the day, it would not impede them in any way
I think it would still like, you know, and me would still have all her like
Magic magic books and stuff in her backpack and so it wouldn't impede her
Ignore the fact that I see has hands. It's her paws and imagine her paws there
Hers would allow her to move quite quickly and if she needed to like fight someone she would but also will help her
I'll make her dance easy and
And I'll make her dance and then she could spend a lot of time doing her DJing
Wait, is she be meant to be transparent? No, I just sketched it out
I just sketched it out so far so that I can get her so I can like put in the colors in soon
I just worked on the shoes and then mom made such a gamer. She's been gaming for like hours, right?
So I figured that like, you know an e-girl outfit
Based off of the reeflings would be like really cute and then of course Azra
I feel like, you know, she'll go on a date with you, but she's got to do some groceries and some toys
And you do you want to go with her? Of course you do
You know, I think those are these are like
Based off of like what I feel about them
So right now I have I'm working on Chibi's right now
I wanted her to have sunglasses and a big hat because why
She wants to be under a shade, you know, she just wants to be beautiful. She wants to be beautiful and
Under the shade and not under the same sun as you
Where will she keep the crop who knows it's magic. All right, I'm heading out to bed to sleep
Sleep. I'm so sleepy. Okay, Azra. Have good sleep. I kiss you and tuck you in
So right now I'm working on Chibi's outfit
I still think I still think they're all fairly good even if they're super sketchy even if they're super sketchy
and I don't have time to
To like block them in and make them look way better
So yeah, this is what you get I
Think they're cute. I
Can definitely do better, but I think they're cute for now
For Chibi's outfit, I think to match her hair. I think it should be kind of like a
Like a bit of a off-white tan ish color
So the outfit I have in mind for Chibi is very business a very business-looking and
She would be wearing
I'm forgetting words now
Oh
Stretchy oh
Can you tell that I'm getting tired, but I don't want to like do like a bad job on Chibi's so
So yeah, it's a peplum peplum trench trench coat look nothing underneath by the way
Uh with a pencil skirt that kind of reveals the
Kind of reveals her like I because the
The stockings are
Just said it
Um
Are like gartered gartered on
So that's why I'm just like, okay, we'll have this look and she will have a very big
beautiful hat so that she can um just
relax and
Have a good time
He gets to stay out of the sun with the big hat
Honestly, if I had a choice, I'll be like yeah out of cane
Out of cane too, but I'm just like the implications of that might be not that great
Relaxing but still girl bossing as I you know, that's Chibi
Just
Ignore the fact that my shading is terrible right now. I'm like what am I doing?
I'm already getting that point where I'm just like I feel kind of delirious
I feel kind of delirious
It's a lot of brainpower to do design if it's just going with the flow with the story
It's cool, too, but I'm just I'm so tired
I
Don't want to do a bad job because I've had this idea in my mind for a while or for Chibi as well
I wanted I wanted to at least look like
There was thought put into this
I
Trench like I've got I'm going for a trench coat look as well
So I think she be look fantastic
And a trench coat
But like underneath I know there's like a bra there, but underneath she would not be wearing anything
Just saying she would not be wearing anything it would just be skin
What does she have under there I don't know it's up to your imagination, but she won't let you know
She won't let you know
I
Block these in already have the idea in my mind, so I think we can just block these in
So that it's a bit more square up here, so I can give it I kind of like boss shoulder pad lady look
The Mercy know what's underneath. I don't know what's underneath. It's up to my imagination as well as your Senpai
I know some people it's hard to see what I'm visioning because I this is this is completely a sketch. This is like
Sketch sketch form and just blocking in the colors and kind of getting the idea out there rather than like formally
Like rendering it out into something like super amazing and stuff so
This is just ideas ideas must come out now
Ideas will come out now and they cannot be stopped
I
Like a blazer jacket yes
But it's peplum a peplum is when it's I kind of like sticks out there at the end going like a skirt like a skirt
So I've always liked that look it gives it such a mermaid, but also very elegant look to it
My opinion
It gives it like that very elegant look and I think it's simple but effective I
Know it's gonna look really funny without without like the line to show it off
So just give me a second
Well, give me a second. I gotta fill in these as well. So
I've always had these like ideas maybe I'll add another one have these ideas for like she
Without it for a while
Nah, she was good
Yeah, she looks better
Okay, let's draw in the details
Just so everyone can see my own vision as well
Ignore the fact that she has so much thighs. It's cuz like, you know, this is my body
She we have less thighs, I think it's just not
The I think the the the torso ratio to thigh is like not as extreme in my opinion
Wait, I don't like that hold on let me redo this
Different pencil
The different
Actually let's
My re kind of redesign reconceptualize the occult
I like it
This
Getting some
There we go. Yes, that looks better
Oh
Yeah, yeah, yeah, there we go
And then
Her her bobs are big but my bobs are not so
Pretend out pretend that is her bobs
Just redraw over it
Yeah
There we go
Yeah, you know what forget it. Okay, forget it. It's even in your mind
Now that someone said like the curious George guy, I'm starting to be like, oh, maybe I should change
Something what the heck now you're making me feel bad
No, I can't even see it either fuck you
I
Was going for like a cream kind of like a trench coat color because of her because of the
Because of the I
I like I liked that it would look probably nice with her hair
Oh my recolor is I work so hard on this too
Oh
I
Cream you're good, but now I can't see it. I can't unsee it. Maybe I should just like block it in with like black instead
Like black instead I thought cream would look good with her with her with her hair
I
Color this in
Maybe black skirt for ballot
Looks oh the racer came on
Yeah, we'll just make her skirt black and then maybe it will it will make make it look less
Like the man
Problem code, sorry, I have problem code to make it look nice
Oh
Let me get like this I can color in
This so be like no bubba's no no
There imagine it nothing underneath. Yep
Oh
There
You know
It might look pretty decent with the
Yeah, I think it looks decent with the the black skirt
And then we're just
Designer sunglasses
She doesn't want to look at you
I
That in some
Color blocks. Yeah
Let's do some color blocks
I
Lock it look it I'm gonna go extra I'm gonna go extra
Her first shawl a first shawl
I
Was like I'm not sure about this idea now. I'm locked in screw it
What do you think
The first date she would come out with this first shawl and should be like bark for me
Oh
If she doesn't like the date she walks away she walks away with her bodyguard saying saying
Saying ban him from from I don't know ban him from from my establishment
I think she be would definitely be like don't look at me
You don't have the right to do that type of look
You
Think she'll say anything at all. Maybe she'll just look at you and just really give you a disgusted face
That's what I envisioned for she be because I was like, oh, yeah, she's business lady and she means business even on her dates
Oh
She'll be so business even on her dates. Oh, oh, I'm exhausted now
I'm exhausted now. Maybe it's maybe I'm just like oh, it's not enough here. Let's make a shawl a little bit longer
Oh
Exhausted I think everyone's outfits pretty frickin nice
Honestly, I think everyone's outfits pretty nice simple
And would
Would
Be realistically in
their in their kind of
Domain of what they do and that they would
They would
Sorry they're in line and what they would do in a comfortable way in which
Which the girls will also be able to work and shine in their best environment
so
So for
Azra, it's a very mommy look
Going out shopping grocery shopping. I would give her a very high ponytail. So hold on. Let me get
her color
I'll put her in a very high ponytail. So ignore that. This is gonna be super sketchy, but
Well
It'll be like
Super high up that it would ask a down
I'm so bad at this. I can't tell distance
I
Just
Hi ponytail probably in a scrunchie and I'll be like, you know
I'll be it be down here, but then it'll probably like, you know an Azra style
cascade down
Stronnies is an e-girl
It's an e-girl she'll play games for hours and hours probably be at home stepping on her little
reef link slippers
I
See would be the princess
the
raving princess
So it will be enough for her to DJ and she'll go to raves and she'll have her little like
Binky binky necklace like diamond binky necklace
And then
In me would be would be like, you know, like, uh-huh cute cute emo goth goth girlfriend little sister
What
Strawneys casual hairdo, I think it would just be like a lobe. I think it would just be like it would just hang down
I think her her her casual hair would just hang down. Maybe a little bit unkempt, you know
This French outfit kind of fire. Yeah, I think so
I
Unkempt from gaming all night. Yeah
What about your safer work outfit? I've decided to not do my own outfit because
Five is already exhausting and I was like, oh
Maybe none for me. Maybe none for me. I think that the girl should come first
Yeah, I think I'll be a little little unkempt
Strawneys hair would be unkempt just from gaming, but I think it's still really cute in this e-girl outfit for her like two bunches
Pig tails. I think that's cute. I
Think that's cute when it's like the two bunches
Describe your date outfit. I wanted like a sweater dress with ribbons
I
Wanted a sweater dress with ribbons on them
That one's cute and that would be a cute idea
And
Like in my mind, I was like, oh, I want to impress my senpai
So I'm gonna curl my hair and leave it down a little bit and put like ribbons in my hair as well
That's my thought
Hahaha and a mustache the mustache is only for an artistic endeavors
About the footwear, um
Mary Jane's Mary Jane's maybe something cute
Maybe loafers, I don't know I
I
Divergent killer sweater. No more like
Kind of the off-the-shoulder sweater, you know those types
Those types of sweaters I think are would have been my my taste
I
Yeah, I'm proud I'm proud of what I did. It's not like super artistic and not like super rendered fully
But I think that it gives you the idea of what I wanted to do for
The girls
So you kind of get the idea
The
Idea of what I was going for I'm kind of I wanted Emmys little hair bunches to like go on the side of her head instead
So it'd be like cute
So that's why I had the arrow pointing up because I was like, I can't figure out how to do this without it looking bad
So yeah, you can see the vision and that's all that matters
Yeah
And I'm kind of
I'm kind of proud of it. I feel like oh, I'm like them. I've been debating on like I
Think it just doesn't
Shibby's outfit is like, huh, maybe if I'd get do it like not this cream color, but maybe like a
Different color, maybe it may be a look better in all black. I'm like debating on like that
I'm like debating on the color
And definitely if this was on Shibby's actual body, it would fit her way better. It's just me. It's just my body
I don't think my body would look looks as good as in pencil skirt simply because
My hips are the hip till like waist ratio does not make it look that great
But I think on Shibby's like body body
Would look much better because I I envisioned this with their actual bodies and then when the time came I was like
Everybody gets my body
Everyone gets mine
It's all mercy except for Azra
It's all me even the canoes they're all me
I
Didn't have time to like
Do their whole with their bodies. I was like, it's just me and then Azra and then me with no boobs are the canoes
So tired
I
So tired now some pie. I think this is gotta be it. There's gotta be it. I know it's not the greatest
I just wanted to like bam bam get the idea out there right now
Well tea time go hi today's tea is gingerbread today's word it's frazzled
So I think yeah get the idea out there and then just blow yeah
Now I'm debating on like Shibby's outfit, I'm just like
I
Know that lay they look really rough. I know that they look really rough, but I'm just like nah
We we we we ball in here and plus I got I've got I have to admit that I have quite a
Background and fashion and design like not in an educational sense
But as a hobbyist sense. Oh, wait, no, no, no my my lore is I am a design student
I was a design student never mind. Yes, I have it in an educational sense
Mercy what time is it for you? Well, I can tell you it's the next day
It's the next day Senpai
Okay
Take a screenshot if any of my wonderful Senpais wanted to like redraw or do like arts of
The girls in these outfits you may do it
I
Always had an interest in fashion for a long time actually one of my dreams when I was like a kid was like fashion designer
That's fine
So
Yeah, if anyone wants to draw my gen mates outfits you may I think it look it would look great
I think if you conceptualize it better than I I just go like bam bam bam. Thank you ma'am
Yeah
You you're free to draw me anytime as well, but I I feel like in relation to the stream
Well, yeah, blow this pic to the twit Twitter, do you guys think I should
You guys think I should Senpai's think I should
Hmm
Okay, it's not the greatest but you know, it's enough for a stream and it's enough to get my ideas out there
They had more time this would probably take a few like maybe a week a week to like fully conceptualize
Shade in and everything and make it look good, but unfortunately we've only got three hours and three hours is enough for
Sketches
Sketches concept art
Oh, yeah, thank you everyone for joining me today. Oh, let's see what's on my schedule
I
Think this week, there's only two more streams left. I think
Tomorrow is harvester. Oh, how exciting I really want to play a harvester. What about the meat Senpai?
Wait, no, it's not the meat the meat
And
As well the following day is death mark and then it's up to a new week
Oh, yeah, I wanted to say because I check finally checked my schedule
Uh, I've checked my schedule. I do have a Q&A
Advice
Column thing or next week. So if any senpais need advice
Feel free to send in something through my morals and I will give you advice
from a complete not professional and
It might be good advice. It might be terrible advice. Who knows?
Mustache gone
Yeah, I send them below would be below in the description will probably have my marshmallow
Mystery advice if you have any troubles feel free to ask mercy will help you
What questions can we send in say for work questions. Thank you. It's a stream after all, please do some say for work questions
I don't know like
You can ask things like like I I want to go I want to go to
I
Have two events. I booked up and I want to go to this one or this one. Which do I choose?
You know those types of questions
You can ask me for investment advice is just that I guarantee you will be a bad advice
Or if you're like, I've been feeling sad lately
What should I do about it? And then maybe I can give you a little bit of advice about things that I would do and you know, yeah
No, not those type of questions silly
Mildly not safe for work as long as it can be put on stream
Then it's safe
Just remember that big brother
Big brother not not it means big bro big brother
YouTube who is always watching keeping a watch roll eye on all of us and fortunately
Smiting us when they can
Uh
Approved so please keep that in mind. We are we are as in we as in be a lore is
Is
Applying for monetization so keep that in mind
Okay, okay
So, yeah, if anything that causes me to get in trouble that's not good at all
If you ask the most sussiest nonniest questions, they will simply be ignored
They will simply be ignored and not appear on stream
So that's all I'm very close to monetization so
Hopefully within like the next few days it will properly count
Properly come
Get to it and then
As they're reviewing content perhaps
Perhaps I was safe
Perhaps I am safe enough for work and that I will continue being safe for work and
Forever ever never do sassy things ever
I will continue doing those types of thing and only doing
Bad things off of the platform as it is not
representative of the YouTube of the YouTube brand
We will be very safe from forever, yes forever
We
We stay TOS compliant every time and we will be a great great asset to the
Making sure that all users are safe on YouTube and not at all
Anything else
Oh
With that Senpai I have I went through all the things
I'm gonna let you go now back into the cage
I'm gonna let you all back into the cage to get some rest for the next day and then we'll play harvester tomorrow. I
Love point and click so hopefully we'll have lots of fun with that. I
Don't mind a little a little bit of back seating when I ask
So yeah, I hope
That you all have a wonderful time have lots of rest and
Take care of yourself also do your homework and watch
Cardcaptor Sakura, thank you
Thank you Senpai and remember screen for mercy
Bye-bye
You